Rogan experience,
just that contrast between this world
that you were so deeply entrenched in
for two in two years and eight months
like that has got to change the way you
look at human life.
Yeah.
Because the Gulf and wealth is so
enormous.
I mean,
they can't imagine the amount of money
it takes to live in Bel Air and,
and the other way around.
I mean,
I think it's very difficult for someone
in California to imagine how little you
can get by on and how close to the earth
or some most people on the planet live
either.
There's a statistic
that I read once that I repeat all the
time because it still baffles me that if
you make more than $34,000 a year,
you're in the one percent of the world
of the world.
Yeah.
Possibly.
And that is probably magnified manyfold
in Ethiopia.
Yeah.
In Ethiopia and Somalia.
I mean it's,
it's very,
um,
you know,
in some ways,
although they want money all the time,
especially if they're criminals.
Um,
the,
the money that we're used to sort of
greasing our path through life around
here is just not available.
It's just not,
not part of the reality.
What do they do with money when they get
it?
Well,
it depends if,
if they're pirates,
they splash out on a fancy car or,
or caught you see fancy cars.
Sure.
Oh yeah,
no,
I was placed in fancy cars.
I mean,
really?
Yeah.
No.
So the pirates had great cell phones,
um,
expensive suv,
weapons that they had bought from abroad
and maybe a weapons possession,
Mogadishu or something like that.
Uh,
but that's not cheap either.
A,
they,
they bragged about how the,
the bullets costs like a dollar.
Each one of them.
I might've been wearing a band of 500
bullets.
Um,
and the cut is expensive,
so lots of things costs an enormous
amount of money in Somalia.
But if you're a,
if you're a very ordinary Somali,
Somali you,
you're getting by on less than a dollar
a day.
So there's the ordinary Somalis who are
not criminals or not pirates at least.
And then you asked the majority,
the majority.
And then you have these pirates that are
essentially
running through the streets in Mercedes
Benz.
They're like,
they're like gangsters.
And that's,
that's actually how one Somali,
who had some connection to Germany.
I'm describing them to me,
you know,
he,
he was wandering around and got kyle
because it was his hometown and in some
way or ancestral ancestral town.
And he had met some,
this was before I got captured.
It was like they were,
you know,
they had wrapped thumping from the SUV.
Did they really?
American rap.
Who knows?
And then they caught us.
We will,
we went back again and they cut to the
chase in another car and we got
separated again.
But this time we were held for a longer
time and whoever,
my aunt,
when she saw us,
Mexico,
she said,
ha ha.
They catch you guys again.
Just jokingly.
Wow.
But the third time was like my,
my dad and my mom came over this crazy
idea because we have brothers,
we had cousins in Sunny California.
And my mom said,
you know,
why don't we just borrow their
passports,
you know,
to cross.
And I don't remember this,
you know,
just found out recently that what
happened,
my brother told me,
my little young brother,
um,
we just like a little girl,
like a full on little girl because I
thought we had a three passports and two
were boys.
One was a girl and we took straws,
the guest and my mom and my aunt,
the forest,
my little brother to be a little girl.
How did they make him look like a girl?
They just in my little girl for two
weeks just to play around,
you know,
they give them a fake name and so and
so.
And he was playing,
you know,
dancing.
No,
I know,
you know,
dancing,
getting ready,
playing with Barbie dolls.
And so he was preparing,
preparing broke deniro,
bro.
Wow.
Getting ready for that row of his life.
How old was he?
He was two.
At least two or three young.
We,
we,
we talk about determinism versus
freewill.
We talk about what are the,
what,
what's created,
what are the possibilities that is
created as Sean Carroll and why?
Why do you think the way you think and
why are you going to say the next thing
you're going to say and is it,
how much of it is biological?
How much of it is your life experience?
How much of it is information that's
dancing in your head?
How much are you interacting with me?
The last thing that I've said to you?
Yeah,
so I had a.
I was on the same Harris,
this podcast.
We had a long conversation about this
because he is very anti freewill and I
think that it's.
I,
I disagree with him,
but I don't care.
I think kind of boring to be honest is
he think it's boring room.
I think it's boring because here's why I
think it's boring because there's two
questions.
One question is how does the world work?
And the other question is what words
should be attached to how the world
works and the first one is interesting
and the second one is kind of boring.
I see what you're saying.
I've seen seminar,
I agree on how the world works,
right?
But I am what philosophers call a
compatiblist when it comes to freewill,
which,
which is,
I don't think that I have some ways of
thinking my way into overcoming the laws
of physics,
right?
Like I'm made of atoms made,
uh,
particles that obey the laws of physics.
If I talk about myself as a large
collection of atoms and particles
obeying the laws of physics,
then clearly there's no free will.
There's just a solution to the equations
and sometimes the wave function branches
and there's now two of me,
but that's whatever it is.
There's no spark of consciousness that
lets me overcome what the equation site
is going to happen.
But guess what?
That's not a fruitful way to go through
your life in terms of talking about
human beings.
When you meet somebody for the first
time and you say like,
you know,
what do you do?
Who are you?
They don't give you a list of their
atoms and say what every atom is doing
and say,
lead you.
Let's go ahead and solve for diggers
equation to figure out what's going to
happen next.
Right?
You tell a story,
you say like you're a person,
you know you grew up in a certain place,
you have a certain jobs,
stuff like that.
You dramatically condense the
information about who you are into a few
salient points,
and among those salient points are I am
a person who thinks and makes decisions.
Every person in the world,
no matter how anti-free will they are
talks about people as if they make
decisions and the reason they do is
because that's how people are.
That's the best way to talk about
people.
It's not like just a compromise,
like if you don't know the atoms and
molecules in somebody's body and you're
not infinitely computationally powerful,
so you can predict the future,
then it's correct to talk about people
as agents who make decisions.
We call that freewill.
I call that freewill.
Most philosophers call it free will.
If you don't want to call it free will
be my guest.
I don't really.
He and he would say,
squids.
This is how we learn to play with the
fuck we play and nobody could touch the
bad brains musically.
Energy on stage,
nothing and I will see these dudes.
I'd be like,
what the fuck are you into?
And then the role models that,
like you said it,
you know,
we need good role models.
There's,
you know,
there's so many fucked up people that
these kids want to emulate today.
You know,
and I see it because I came up in New
York,
I worked in all the underground hip hop
clubs.
I work for the Pope Pot.
I used to deliver part to all the rap
stars.
I deliver pot pot,
my friend a.
do Matt Work for Tristar.
You can yo meet me at the Boston Comedy
Club.
There's this black comedian there and
he's going to be fucking huge and I
would show up on my bike and you know
who you know,
who the fuck it was?
Dave spelled Dave Chappelle,
Dave Chappelle.
And when he did half baked,
did you notice that he put the weed
delivery guy in all bike gear will fuck
you dig.
He got that from.
I used to show up.
I never carried a bag.
I showed up with a $40,000.
Carbon free boat.
Carbon fiber frame and I had a black
water bottle and all the weed bags was
into two water bottles.
So it just looked like I was a cyclist
out on a motherfucking out on a ride.
Dave Chappelle.
Yeah.
And then Dave,
Dave Chappelle,
when he blew up so fast,
Matt was the guy's name.
He was the publicist at Tristar pitches
and then I delivered to him into Boston
Comedy Club.
And within like months he was living in
some police show fucking spot on,
like second avenue and 15th in the
guild.
Had a fuck.
Did you get from there?
You know,
there was one flight to where he was
like in the center of the Octagon
Control and Peter struycken and like,
I forget who was,
might've been the name of it,
have been somebody else,
but he,
uh,
he actually stopped and step back and
put us back to the fence and say,
come on,
let's fight on the fence now.
And he backed his self.
Oh,
bond.
That's right.
And that's when he got caught with a
spin and elbow.
Was it a no,
Stephan Bonner
tried to spinning back,
kick him and he just slid out of the way
and they went right back to the fence
and went,
come on.
That's what it was.
Exactly.
Fucked him up.
I think he hit him with the need of the
body and then dropped him and then and
then beat the shit out of him.
Yeah,
that was just,
he was just so calm and relaxed in there
and bonner was so stiff and tight and I
think that was it.
Yeah.
I've worked with Stephen for a bunch of
fights.
I didn't work on for that but I don't
recall,
but that was also fight.
We're,
I think Bonner pissed hot.
I think he had an opportunity.
Yeah,
I think he just like,
listen,
I got some injuries where I'm just going
to juice it up.
Dude.
Pissed hot is better than shit hot.
Cause when he fought Sam Hogart at the
Thomas Mack arena,
he fucking shit himself during the Sam.
Sam Hogan was like,
Bro,
it's like on top.
And they grab and he's like,
Bro,
you fucking stinky shit yourself.
And he's like,
yes,
I did stuff in.
The worst part about is we come
backstage,
you know the tea cups,
they like the string up,
the crap,
the crack.
He's like,
coach,
get my cup.
And I was like,
Bro,
you're on your own home.
I ended up with scissors and cut it off.
I'm good.
So hilarious.
Did I got the corner I think for that
fight with the Great Carlson Gracie at
the time when that happened.
Several Times.
Dude,
what was one that get themselves?
Shit himself once.
When we went,
when we run to the,
went to the Reebok uniforms and dudes
wearing white.
I was like,
Bro,
that idea.
No white shorts.
Like stay away from white shorts like
Brown.
I think you're well dude.
You well vert mirrored the definition.
Yeah,
I think he shouted one of his fights one
time.
Michael Kia.
So when he fought biennials right before
the fight started,
he leans over to me.
He goes,
dude,
my.
Remember that before the walk,
do they almost had to postpone the walk.
Yeah,
man.
He was going to run to UFC.
Fight started.
Yeah,
UFC staff.
He was in the tunnel getting ready to
walk.
He's like,
Bro,
I got to go the bathroom.
They're like,
Nah,
no,
you're good.
You're gonna.
He's like,
just let them go wrong.
How long did it take?
Thirty seconds.
We'll cover,
let the guy took a dump,
right,
and then right behind him,
production time,
the format,
fucking schedule,
whatever it is,
but do what a man's got a shit.
He's got a shit.
Yeah.